et le dija qui est la forge pour le
groupe modem
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Jean-Noël Barrault
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et les télécommunications et
elle porte sur les zones blanches
persistantes à la fois pour le réseau
mobile et pour le fixe pour assurer une
couverture mobile sur tout le territoire
et résorber la fracture numérique le
gouvernement a depuis 4 ans engagé le
New Deal le New Deal mobile mais les
opérateurs de téléphonie mobile quant à
eux n'ont pas toujours rempli leur part
de leur du contrat en effet de trop
nombreuses communes sont encore
aujourd'hui touché par l'absence totale
ou partielle du réseau entre couverture
inexistante et coupure régulière la
situation de ses habitants leur est
insupportable alors que tous nos
concitoyens ont besoin de leur téléphone
se pose également la question de la
sécurité des habitants mais aussi des
touristes sachez qu'en Isère dans le
secteur du royaume Vercors même le
réseau s'affirent pourtant utilisé par
nos forces de gendarmerie et
inaccessible dans certaines zones assez
difficultés de réseaux mobiles s'ajoute
des problèmes sur le réseau filaire
toujours par rénover dans certains
territoires c'est donc une double peine
pour les habitants qui n'ont donc ni
réseau mobile stable ni réseau fixe
fiable et encore moins la fibre bien
évidemment donc face à ces défaillances
j'avais personnellement sollicité orange
l'opérateur historique qui m'avait
répondu alors je cite il faudra bien
vivre avec le réseau existant monsieur
le ministre les citoyens et les élus
particulièrement des zones rurales et de
montagnes ne voient pas leur situation
s'améliorer et s'impatiente à l'heure où
le télétravail s'est imposé pour
beaucoup ces zones blanches pointent les
inégalités territoriales de notre pays
et rendent ces régions moins attractives
je connais votre engagement sur ce sujet
et je sais pouvoir compter sur votre
implication ma question est donc comment
comptez-vous mettre les opérateurs face
à leur responsabilité je vous remercie
ma chère collègues la parole est un
chant de Noël barreau ministre délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée la France ne
tiendra son rang de grande nation du
numérique que si l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sont desservis par les
réseaux télécommunications fixes et
mobiles et lorsque toutes les zones
blanches auront été effacées s'agissant
des réseaux fixes le plan France très
haut débit initié il y a 10 ans se
poursuit se déploie la France et le pays
le mieux fibré en Europe mais il faut
veiller au rythme et à la qualité des
déploiements et c'est la responsabilité
de l'ARCEP de le faire s'agissant du
mobile je veux rendre hommage à Julien
de Normandie à Jacqueline Gouraud à
Cédrico qui constatant les difficultés
des opérateurs à couvrir certaines zones
peu dense on quitte initié le programme
du New Deal mobile qui était un
programme de réussite de confiance de
coopération entre l'État les
collectivités et les opérateurs puisque
c'est au niveau départemental que sont
identifiés les lieux d'implantation des
sites et ça fonctionne en quelques
années plusieurs milliers de zones
blanches ont été effacées 3795 pour être
exact donc 49 dans votre département
madame la députée il faut évidemment
aller plus loin puisque l'objectif
c'était de couvrir 5000 sites en 2025 et
en 2023
600 sites seront attribués dont 9 dans
votre département dans votre
circonscription quatre communes sont
encore classifiées en zone blanche elles
ont été
identifiées en zone prioritaire et je
peux d'ores et déjà vous annoncer que
pour trois d'entre elles chorange
Chatelus Saint-Pierre de cherene et
Presles les implantations auront lieu
d'ici 18 mois vous le voyez madame la
députée mesdames et messieurs les
députés nous travaillons
papier pour faire en sorte que
s'agissant du fixe ou du mobile
l'ensemble du territoire national soit
couvert que les zones blanches soient
totalement effacées avec une vigilance
particulière pour les zones de montagne
et pour les zones rurales
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre